[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
aujourd'hui je le savais je vous dis la
vérité je vaux a conquis demain et après
demain je suis pas là parce que je suis
en grand partie en grand pardon ça veut
dire tu ai pas envie d ces deux jours
pour me recentrer sur moi même on prend
les grandes décisions et je savais je
n'allais pas être là mardi et mercredi
est la personne qui était notre invité
devenir mardi j'ai fait j'ai pris alors
j'avais deux solutions ou j'annule et
qui pour mais pour tout le monde à
l'international à venir j'appelle et
rabat les trucs ou des classes de doha à
moi je me suis peut-être on est short ou
jeu décalé l'invité de mardi à lundi et
j'ai choisi la deuxième solution
alors viens nous voir pour lire elle va
faire une nouvelle émission elle est
aussi voilà on la connaît dont le truc
là christina claudio téléspectateurs tu
crois même si je regarde les rênes du
shopping moi je regarde la star
programme testing à cordoue la démarque
you are marque ben merci merci importe c
est mal gérée mais lille on dit je
regarde ces six-là cordula dix pages
regarde les rênes du charme mais qu'est
ce qu'on s'en fout du titre aujourd'hui
le titre c'est rien le dimanche on dit
je regarde drucker on dit pas je regarde
vivement dimanche
elles ont dit je regarde riquet lundi je
regarde c'est que de la télé
[Applaudissements]
devenez la meilleure version de vous
même ce sera dans ce qu'il ne fallait
pas louper
je t'ai intégré dans l'émission tel un
gratin dans un four c'est pas là pour
être fait tant d'années je vais quand
même lui montrer par acquis de
conscience
j'adore j'adore les voilà on a dans les
stades
[Rires]
smoking
on adore je donne bien
[Applaudissements]
j'attends de ces coûts propos est vrai
que plusieurs intéressés puissent en
absurdie vous avez vous ne verrez sortie
face à hugo et moundir est aussi bas que
ces catastrophique sauveur tu vas faire
pis pour toi sale athènes je suis fille
80 ma vie
demandez pas qui je suis
tu peux
on savait que des recommandés même pour
les garçons de faire pipi assis et sur
la lunette passe quand on fait pipi
debout ya plein plein plein de petites
et ou qui partent sur les murs et
façades et moi je m'amuse à faire un
truc que je vous le dise pas si vous
faites non gestionnaire puis de plus en
plus longs mais j'adore moi je n'ai pas
pour le mètre carré
je fais ça mais écoutez moi bien à
l'appât du péché dans le salon doit
savoir les gens ils sont fontaine de 13
faire pipi dans les restaurants les
trucs là les cuves là quand même
ouais ouais c'est horrible parce que si
vous pisse fait pipi de trop près ça
truc et ça revient sur sa saison parce
que pour avoir du pupille étrangers dit
sur vous ça mais ça ça te fait un garrot
pas donc moi aussi qu'est ce que je fais
j'ouvre la porte du restaurant et je
vois le truc qui est loin non merde à
cela et je suis comme ça tu survis j'ai
hérité bien avec nous comme oui mais la
moule agacé la limite
abobo
et là est un truc qui est horrible aussi
c'est parfois quand vous allez dans un
hôtel vous venez d'arriver dans la
chambre et vous voyez un vieux poil noir
qui n'est pas le vôtre qui est collée
contre la douche
oh là là là là c'est un deux étoiles
mais même alors même dans les palaces je
vous le dis moi ça m'est arrivé aussi
bien dans des une étoile tout à des
formules à queue dans des formules wan
hé oui je prends le poil je donne à la
balistique au labo retrouver cette place
je fais mieux moi faites moi je fais
exprès de m'arracher un poil et le
collet avant le parti d'arrêter un doux
et non mais devinez non non je vous les
offrons de ma non pas du tout pour voir
pour voir s'ils vont bien drôle vers
derrière voilà et après j'avais la
personne n'a pris la chambre monde mais
ce que je connais mon numéro de la
chambre passez-moi la 312 oui bonjour
est ce que vous avez vu un poil de vue
que dans l'ajout du blender jeu du
werder
je vous dis c'est un blond polaire toi
la c1 lavande
c'est un bois alors je te dis donc pas
se voir parce que ce que je vais faire
c'est que j'ai de faire un champion bull
non mais c'est vrai tu mets une petite
tête mais je te dis je vais patiner ça
tu passe demain j'en ai pour une petite
demi-heure alors qu'ils me voir au salon
demain t'inquiète pas
[Musique]